no one welcome to this video playing
super Sasha let's check mark back which
we are planing before good score just
considered have a point out of three
games ok let's go for my line here you
have amazed how many people go for the
t5 line I mean it is not as bad as
probably a wow that's probably not as
bad as some sources suggest but it's
still not good yeah not really good ok
what is he doing them not taking with
the porn yeah but totally totally
playable
yeah where to how to take now yeah I
think I'll take with the e porn they
have the hanging porns here always
always tricky to play but in this
particular situation I thought that the
Queen on d5 can be a problem for black
this in particular
yeah to see doing now night back I
announced to take he knows me to take it
yeah I wasn't I wasn't entirely sure how
good it is to take to be perfectly
honest maybe Queen d2 threatening to
take and then queen age six if I would
have taken immediately you might have
some Queen age five okay here you can
move the can move the night of course 27
or something something like that
yeah I don't think he can just allow
Bishop age six Queen h6 Bishop f6 Queen
86 something like 9 a-5 is not possible
I don't believe it
97 mania that it might be on okay then i
can take and play Bishop before probably
yeah I think he needed to do that looks
looks risky of course so what now Queen
f4 Queen age forum I guess and peace
base the tech
it looks more than dangerous g6 so c4
and it's go see for Q&A 5 or how is he
doing how does he do it now kept maybe
you can go these two g6 actually this is
what this is the sound estimated okay
it's not a big deal it's just that I
didn't see that this move is still
pretty resilient rotating Bishop g6 and
rookie 6 + f5 is well what a move you
want to play 9 f8 I can just take and
then take is 6 this is almost a double
attack of some sorts
the only thing that irritates me if I
take with the rook this so some I'm
putting myself into a sinner into a pin
down but okay it's probably not a big
problem i have d 5 if i go daddy five
yeah i can do that d 50 I didn't think
about that at all it's that good though
um okay I can take and Bishop g62 takes
rook takes rook 27 27 wins yeah that
wins anyway right
um oh I guess what you soon maybe just
seven something that a giant could have
played black resins it could have played
work too soon ok so in this position
yeah I said it seems like somewhat
favorable hanging porn position here
because that Queen on d5 I know it
doesn't doesn't look internally right
for black but it's probably it's nothing
nothing terrible so you just I think it
gets it gets tricky shortly here Queen
d2 yeah I think that is an interesting
move on threatening Bishop f6 queen age
six now and I think he has to move that
night or now ninety-seven is something
that I was thinking okay I've got this
actually okay didn't see that move
that's very strong and something like
this this is a deadly attack with the
rookin into the game so here and now
that gets tricky I'm checking with all
the pieces now okay our computer wants
to go see for here it's even stronger
okay yeah yeah because here I'm winning
the exchange just material gain 26mm not
possible and if the Queen moves I have
this strong threatening here and here
it's very strong and okay but this isn't
bad right c4 in here it is by far not as
convincing yeah he has to go at five I
mean like it or not you have to
black probably has to play something
like this according to the engine and
this is a min not winning for white it's
just 0.8 0.9 so not like a direct win so
I grabbed here i was thinking 98
actually and here i thought that well
he's not threatening that much here
because of the of the fork I thought I
have maybe just 94 move like that yeah I
did sir it is good for White he went
here though big sticks and now I
probably made a mistake Bishop g6e
kangaroo g7 I i saw that too late and
that is not a completely clear position
this loses out right and okay that's
that i calculated but he can do this and
check i can i can check for this line
but it is not let's not acknowledge win
at all ah there was the soft spot other
a tricky spot in that case I and my
channel I'm just winning the Queen okay
he was under time pressure after he had
spent and quite some chunks of time
early on so it was difficult for him to
defend this precisely okay well thanks
for watching